governor greg abbott has asked president
biden to issue an emergency declaration
at the border writing the surge poses
life-threatening risks to residents of
valverde county and is quickly
overrunning law enforcement health care
and humanitarian resources which were
never intended to be used in this
capacity governor abbott joins me now
governor good to see you tonight
do you expect your request to be granted
you know i have not yet heard from the
president during this his entire
presidency concerning the border uh the
by administration refuses to even
pretend as though there's a crisis and
obviously as you've been talking about
tonight and as your viewers have seen
for months now there is chaos down there
especially in the del rio sector and so
the democrats made clear let's go back
one year ago back when the democrats
were sharing a debate stage and you had
joe biden and kamala harris and beto
o'rourke and others all talking about
how they wanted to have open border
policies in the united states americans
probably had no idea it was going to
lead to this level of chaos as you saw
all those people streaming across the
border lord there was a report out today
the report contained comments by a
border patrol agent the border patrol
agent said that the reason why control
was able to be gained
in the del rio sector today is because
of the texas department of public safety
what we did we put hundreds of texas
department of public safety cars and
created a steel wall a steel wall of dps
vehicles that prevented anybody from
crossing that
dam that you've seen people walk across
walking into the state of texas we
effectively as the officer said regain
control of the border in the rio grande
sector because the texas department of
public safety stepped up this is going
to be
as long as chaos
administration is in charge yeah well of
course he doesn't call you and he's i
don't know who he's calling but he's has
a lot of time to spend in jerobot beach
but governor there was a video earlier
today of border agents on horseback
um trying to move migrants uh the
beltway media reported it as if you know
there were horse rains where actually
whips
uh of course that narrative took hold
today
should we be looking at the budget of
department of homeland security because
i was not aware
that whips people had that kind of
equipment on them that they could use on
humans the fact that we are dealing with
mainly black
migrants and black immigrants and asylum
seekers at our border in this kind of
way really speaks to the the kind of
racism systematic racism that is
embedded in that department
uh the white house says they're
investigating this uh your response
governor
well first these reports come from
people who probably have never ridden a
horse before and don't understand what
rains are in the way that you use rains
as you are maneuvering a horse but
second and most importantly laura and
that is they would not have to be
responding to the migrants in any way
whatsoever if they did their job and
stop people from coming across the
border texas has obtained a federal
court order against the blind
administration requiring the
administration to keep in place
president trump's remaining mexico
policy biden is in violation of that
federal court order if biden followed
that court order we would not see the
chaos that we are seeing in del rio
today governor do you know how much this
is costing your state in terms of
dollars and cents just in the added
health care costs uh alone
let alone the humanitarian issues that
are involved
any clue well i just
sure well just a few days ago
i signed the most recent budget that
included three billion dollars more and
that is just for border security alone
not counting the health care costs or
the education costs or the other costs
which would be in the
billions more and so this is very costly
but laura very importantly it doesn't
stop in texas it goes to states across
the entire country whether it be the
deadly fentanyl or
the other costs the health care costs et
cetera those costs will be borne by
fellow americans in states across the
entire country governor how worried are
you about beto o'rourke jumping into the
race for governor are you sweating that
three strikes and you're out
in other words you're not going to get
on the stage and do punk rock with them
anytime soon all right governor good to
see you tonight hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else